elden ring has three endings with an
extra three variants on the vanilla
ending leading to a total of six
at least six that we know of at the
moment there are a few theories of even
more endings but so far they're not
confirmed
and despite being more straightforward
in explanation than its predecessors
elden ring still leaves a lot unsaid and
this means the endings may seem a bit
vague so in this video i'm going to do
my best to explain each of the six
endings and what they mean lore wise to
the world of the lands between
first i want to note that all of the
endings include the final boss fight a
two-phase gauntlet first against radagon
vessel of the elden ring and then
against the elden beast an eldritch
space worm thing which is a
representative of the greater will and
that became the elden ring itself
there is plenty of lore to discuss with
these two but they don't differ between
the endings so they won't be as much a
focus of this video i'll suffice to say
that radagon is merica and they are a
conflicted vessel or housing of the
elden ring
according to the item description for
america's hammer the weapon they used
during their fight with hammer in hand
america shattered the elden ring and
then radagon attempted to repair it they
are meant to be the god of the lands
between but it seems that america
developed other plans
the elden beast however is higher up on
the food chain according to the
incantation eldon stars
long ago the greater will sent a golden
star bearing a beast into the lands
between which would later become the
elden ring the greater will is a great
outer god one of at least a few which
exists outside the lands between
it is essentially the greater god of the
elden ring the er tree and the golden
order it's also very lovecraftian so the
elden beast is a vassal of the greater
will and a living incarnation of the
concept of order it is also essentially
the elden ring itself the centerpiece of
mainstream civilization if we can call
it that that exists in the lands between
once you overcome this utterly annoying
boss fight you are left on the stone
platform to make your choice between the
endings of elden ring
the basic vanilla ending is that of
becoming the elden lord there are four
variants on this ending with the most
straightforward being that of the age of
fracture
most nbc's point you towards becoming
the elden lord it seems like that's the
whole goal of the return of the
tarnished it's what the two fingers and
everyone in the round table hold says is
what you need to do so if you do it and
you play through the game without
pursuing any extra quests you get this
ending you become the elden lord and
usher in the age of fracture you do this
by returning the head of fractured
america and restoring the elden ring
with you as its lord a golden hue
returns to the sky and land and you sit
on the throne but you may notice that
the light is not of shining gold in the
shots of the leaves and the throne the
light is more like that of a sunset with
your shadow clearly visible in the
orange light almost like the sun is
setting on this age despite your recent
ascension to lord
this is pretty unsurprising for from
software this age of fracture reads like
a simple continuation of the problems
that led to the start of the game the
cycle is continued with nothing truly
resolved
often times the most straightforward
ending in fromsoft games is not the one
that thematically resolves the issues of
the game to some extent in dark souls
and really in dark souls 3 the basic
ending of relinking the flame is simply
prolonging the issue continuing a cycle
of stagnation that really should
probably be broken the age of fracture
is just that the lines between are still
broken and beholden to the whims of the
greater will
the sun is setting on this age one
unquestionably afflicted by stagnation
and one with not a thing resolved this
basic ending doesn't rock the boat but
it doesn't lead to a resolution either
now we can explore the variant endings
where you still become an elden lord but
bring about a different age first is the
age of order this ending is achieved by
completing the questline for gold mask
and brother corin
adherence of the golden order and the
faith of the erd tree completing their
questline brings about the mending rune
of perfect order an item you can pick up
from a dead gold mask this unlocks a
choice at the end of the game to use
this rune to mend the elden ring with
and if you do so a golden circle
surrounds the elden ring at the center
of america golden light fills the sky
and shines down from above showering you
the elden lord and gold the description
for the mending rune of perfect order
states that it is a rune of
transcendental ideology which will
attempt to perfect the golden order the
current imperfection of the golden order
or instability of ideology can be blamed
upon the fickleness of the gods no
better than men that is the fly in the
ointment it also states that it was
discovered not created by gold mask an
important distinction that will come up
later with the other variants so this
sounds like a better ending than the age
of fracture a flaw in the golden order
was noticed and gold mask a ceaseless
watcher of the ergery discovered a
possible solution
though brother corin is not so sure if
you speak to him in the asheville
capital he is on verge of a mental break
the master was nothing more than a
madman
enchanted by a vain and ruinous delusion
he rejected the perfection of the golden
order
seeking to supplant our glorious faith
with his own
could there be a more pitiable comedy
look at it the culmination of perfection
burning
before our very eyes
[Laughter]
he says that gold mask was actually a
madman and that his final attempt to fix
things his discovery is tantamount to
heresy a rejection of the golden order
now even if corn isn't the sound as
judge the description of the rune claims
the current imperfection is caused by
the fickleness of the gods no better
than men
but the new order we create rests on us
the tarnish and who's to say we do not
share in such fickleness
there's no evidence that we as the
player character or any other tarnished
in terms of virtue are any better than
the gods the new order may have a golden
light but it still seems to do its best
to maintain the status quo of the elden
ring and the greater will the age of
order is an improvement on the age of
fracture but it seems at best to be a
better prolonging of fate and a
continuation of subjugation by an outer
god
next is the age of the duskborn brought
about by completing the questline of
death associated with fia finishing this
questline will award the player with the
mending rune of the death prince a rune
gestated but not discovered by fia this
ending has the death prince rune
circumscribe the bottom of the elden
ring
then a misty grey shrouds the world a
rain of seeming ash under which no leaf
stirs in this grey rain we sit as elden
lord of a land that will know death for
the first time in ages
the rune of the death prince is made up
of the two curse marks of death which
appeared at the time of the death of the
first demigod this rune creates an order
of death restored a return of death
after its confinement during the
creation of the original golden order
this also via hopes stays the
persecution of those who live in death
no longer to be hunted by the likes of
people like dee
so this is a significant departure from
the original order as it brings back a
core element of existence that the order
removed the concept and possibility of
death despite this being another elden
lord ending the original intent of the
elden ring and the greater will seems to
actually be mired to what extent is left
unclear though as you still become an
elden lord and conventionally restore
the elden ring this might just be a bump
in the road for the designs of the
greater will
now the possibility of death does allow
for some thematic resolution because the
stagnation of endlessly living now has
an answer death
however the simple presence of death
doesn't seem to metaphysically change
the world or the overarching situation
of the lands between
so i'm not sure we can say that this
ending brings with it much meaningful
change
the final variant of becoming an elden
lord is the blessing of despair brought
about by completing the dung eater's
questline finishing this quest line will
award the player with the mending rune
of the fel curse a loathsome rune
gestated by the dung eater this ending
has the fel curse rune cover the elden
ring with its decrepit blight the world
is covered by an apocalyptic sky of
swirling orange sores the herd tree is a
pale white the leaves don't stir and the
throne is surrounded by a dank fog and
the fel curse defines the age one of a
blessing of despair this ending is a
fitting one to pair with the dung eater
a reviled curse of a man in his own
right and from him we can learn more
about this blessing of despair the
seabed curse the item which is needed to
progress dung's quest and achieve this
ending states that it is a curse grown
on a corpse killed and defiled by the
dung eater a tender pox afflicted with
omen horns
by doing so he prevents dead souls
returning to the erd tree leaving them
forever cursed one of the most loathsome
things found in the lands between
so this action is a travesty to the
normal order the description of the
curse rune says that when it is used on
the elden ring that the curse will last
eternally afflicting every generation of
the world
but what is this affliction really we
know it prevents souls from returning to
the urgery but if the order and the
urgery are not benevolent entities then
this might not be a bad thing it could
be that with that in mind we can
understand the name of this ending how
despair can be a blessing
after all the description of the curse
rune also states if order is defiled
entirely defilement is defilement no
more and for every curse a cursed
blessing
perhaps this total defilement of the
order is able to bring out a world where
separation from the erd tree is a
blessing maybe such a separation could
constitute a proper end to existence a
true death also important to note is the
connection of the fel omen the seedbed
curse has omen horns the full rune name
is mending rune of the fel curse and the
dung eater's helm describes itself as a
malformed helm resembling an omen with
its horns cut off
so not the boils or pus that it might
originally seem but cut off omen horns
is what dons the dung eater's armor the
helm also states of the dung eater
himself that he has the heart of an omen
without the body to match could there be
any crueler existence what does it
matter then if the curse claims it all
so there are inexorable links to the
omen cursed and reviled beings and this
reads a bit nihilistic after the
suffering the omen have endured
responding in kind by cursing the world
so is this really a blessing found
through despair or simply a curse by
another name
there are also possible connections to
the boss moak twin of morgan and lord of
blood he has a connection with an outer
god other than the greater will one
called the mother of truth or the
formless mother who bestows power upon
accursed blood like the blood of the
omen some players think there might be
another secret ending called the age of
the blood that deals with moog but
nothing concrete has been found
though a connection between this
blessing of despair ending and the
secrets of the omen does seem
unquestionable
okay so that ends the variance of the
elden lord ending next is the second
major ending the age of stars
this ending is brought about by
completing the witch ronnie's questline
and summoning her to the stone platform
initiating her blue summon sign will
bring about a wholly new cutscene in
which ronnie is the one who returns the
head of fractured america
and then she speaks
to every living being and every living
soul
now cometh the age of the stars
a thousand-year voyage under the wisdom
of the moon
here beginneth the chill night that
encompasses all
reaching the great beyond
into fear
doubt
and loneliness
as the path stretches into darkness
before you then take her hand as her
eternal consort
this ending is both ominous and
optimistic themes of fear doubt and
loneliness are usually dark and
frightful but they also symbolize
independence and a breakaway from
dogmatic ideology such as the faith of
the golden order and urgery
you can actually speak with ronnie again
after finishing her quest but before
this ending there is a new grace at the
top of her eyes and here she explains
the order she envisions
i take it thousands
i shouldn't be surprised
i thought i might expound a little
further
upon the order i envisioned mine will be
an order not of gold
but the stars and moon of the chill
night
i would keep them far from the earth
beneath our feet
as it is now
life and souls and order abound tightly
together
but i would have them at a great remove
and have the certainties of sight
emotion faith and touch
all become impossibilities
which is why i would abandon this soil
with mine order
what's thou come to me even now
my one and only lord
this dialogue falls in line with the
final cut scene ronnie rejects the
machinations of the greater will and its
representative the two fingers no order
of its gold will be had instead an order
of loneliness where people do not have
the crutch of fate but perhaps
through this they gain greater control
of their own path choosing how they wish
to make their way through the darkness
ronnie mentions
the description of celestial do the item
you use to absolve your sins in the
church of vows might also hint at this
it states once upon a time the stars of
the night sky guided fate and this is a
recollection of those times
a time when the night stars guided fate
could mean there's some outer god
associated with knight and stars but it
could also mean something like what
humans in our own world have done using
stars to navigate seas and lands saving
stories and legends in the
constellations
in our new dark under the stars we can
find our own path and make use of the
night sky as a tool not for dogmatic
decree but as a part of our personal
journey
so and this is obviously my
interpretation a lot of this is
this age of stars ending bears
similarity to what i would call the best
or canon ending of dark souls 3 where
you summon the fire keeper and let the
flame go out that ending too is ominous
but it is also one of hope a facing the
new darkness to grow and progress and
doing so with the fire keeper by your
side
in elden ring we the player take the
more secondary role as ronnie's consort
but the motifs and thematic resolution
are pretty much the same
this really leads me to favor this
ending as the one most in line with the
driving themes of the story it gives the
most resolution to the kinds of ideas
touched on in the story and it seems to
me to be the best fit for a best or
hannon ending
obviously fromsoft leaves these endings
interpretational because they enjoy the
aspect of players determining their own
story in the game but even in a meta way
this ending aligns with that kind of
vision because it's the ending most free
from control of any outside force it is
the ending symbolic of the player making
their own story
and i also want to point out that this
interpretation of the endian can find
support in the philosophy of frederick
nietzsche which bears influence not only
on berserk an inspiration for the dark
fantasy of fromsoft and something
directly paid homage to in this game of
elden ring but it also bears influence
directly on some of fromsoft's themes
the ever striving and overcoming
challenge especially in relation to the
self was extremely central to nietzsche
and the themes present in this ending
mirrors a lot of his work in the books
the spoke zarathustra beyond good and
evil and the gay science
nietzsche saw the end of faith in our
own world the death of god as he put it
as leaving us stranded in fear and
isolation just as ronnie says
but while the end of this grand illusion
may be disconcerting it is also freeing
nietzsche writes finally the horizon
seems clear again even if not bright
finally our ships may set out again set
out to face any danger every darian of
the lover of knowledge is allowed again
the sea
our sea lies open again maybe there has
never been such an open sea
just like the open sea of nietzsche the
horizon of the age of stars is not
bright but it is clear
darkness abounds but the stars dot the
sky and the living beings of the lands
between are free to make their own
voyage
finally we have the third main ending
the lord of frenzied flame this ending
is different because it is achieved by
finding and interacting with the three
fingers at some point during the game
not the two fingers but the three
fingers the ones behind the spells of
frenzy and frenzied flame once this
interaction condition is met you are
locked into the ending and you activate
it by simply interacting with fractured
america at the end of the game
you can actually unlock yourself from
this ending but to achieve it you have
to be locked into it if you find the
three fingers below the capital before
you end the game you become marked with
burns and fingerprints and your eyes
take on the glow of the chaos flame
then at the end you become lord of the
frenzied flame
the head of fractured america will
crumble your head will be replaced by an
orb of chaos flame and that flame will
engulf the world obliterating the earth
tree and setting the lands between a
light and yellow fire and fingerprints
of the three fingers
there is no narration to this ending
just the sound of fire crackle and
smolder and ominous howls and strings
the very sky itself seems to burn
so this ending is ostensibly bad the
utter destruction is hard to view as
anything else but it is important to
understand what's happening before he
passed judgment
if you complete hayet's questline she is
waiting nearby the three fingers she can
become your maiden and tell you the
words of the three fingers all that
there is came from the one great
then came fractures
and births
and souls
but the greater will made a mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melt it all away with the yellow chaos
flame
until all
is won again
the three fingers would have you burn it
all away with the chaos flame until all
is won again
in evangelion fashion
so this ending is one of coalescence
through a destructive process all is
brought together into one entity this
one great is ambiguous perhaps
everything was once it or perhaps it
formed a single outer god or all the
life in the realm of the lands between's
world it is also hard to see exactly the
relation between the greater will and
the entity behind the three fingers what
the wiki calls the frenzied flame if we
take the two fingers and the three
fingers together we get five fingers or
a whole hand perhaps they used to be
this one great before the greater will
split them to create its own path or
domain
there is also the fact that the frenzied
flame and its incantations have to do
with madness many of the incantations
turn others mad which plays into the
lovecraftian idea of his great old ones
otherworldly gods or entities from space
encountering these beings is too much
for a human mind to comprehend
so in lovecraft's stories it goes mad or
insane when it nears them
the outer gods of eldon ring share many
parallels with lovecraft's deities
especially in the ocean sea monster that
is the elden beast and in the
incomprehensibility of the frenzied
flame while this ending is a departure
from the plans of the greater will it is
simply an arrival into the plans of
another great being another outer god
the subsuming of everything into the
yellow flame also seems to bleak to be a
satisfying ending to our tale it is
surely an intriguing and grandiose
finale but it leaves out much of the
rich themes present throughout the story
oh and i almost forgot one more thing if
you lock into this ending before melina
burns herself your body acts as kindling
and she doesn't die
instead we get a new cutscene at the end
of melina with eyes switched promising
to hunt us down
she is reminiscent of ronnie with their
respective closed eyes and ronnie's
shadow face and overall i have little
reason to think that melano is a
malicious actor so i'm chalking this up
to another point against this ending as
achieving proper resolution
so there we have the known endings to
eldon ring explained i do want to make
note that another theorized yet
unconfirmed ending the age of absolute
is one that has been tossed around a bit
and with more substantiation than the
age of blood this ending of the absolute
is supported by data mines of the closed
network tests which reveal continuations
of the quest lines for some npcs npcs
like nephili liu kenneth hayt and
gustock go stock ghost gastak
i don't really remember how to pronounce
his name there's also the section of
stormville castle that prevents combat
likely because it was intended to house
npcs like the round table hold so it
seems that there actually is something
real to this ending with it likely being
another variation of the elden lord
ending affected by finishing an npc
questline
in any case whether it was cut currently
in a glitched form or saved for a dlc
there has so far been no evidence that
it is an achievable ending to the game
at this moment if by the time this video
comes out there is such evidence please
let me know since i have yet to see it
and that does it for my analysis of the
endings in eldon ring plenty of what i
have discussed here could do for its own
standalone video there's lots of lore
with all of these endings and the
characters and the quest lines and i
will likely make some of those videos
along with other lore videos on the game
so thank you for watching and be sure to
stick around if you're looking to
discover more of the lore of the lands
between
and leave in the comments your own lore
theories and if i got anything wrong
there is lots of interpretation in this
video and there are lots of items in the
game that i'm sure i haven't really
delved fully deep into so if you have
another interpretation and you have
something in game to support it i'm all
ears the comment section is your
playground
[Music]
hey
[Music]